Let's go to Bethany from Oklahoma. Bethany
from Oklahoma. You're on the air.
Hi, can you hear me? Yes, I can. Oh, perfect.
I I actually hopped on here not and not even
realizing you were filming, I was just hoping
to catch you. I don't know what time you will
start the show. So I happen to hop on and
I got called. This is crazy beautiful. I guess
my question is, and in the past few days,
you've been talking about how Biden is being
and being criticized for all of his executive
orders. Yes. And we talked about how he's
doing what people want him to do. But the
critique I'm seeing from liberal friends is
that since we control the House and the Senate
now, why isn't he going about it through legislation?
Because he doesn't necessarily have to get
Republicans on board, does he?
So a couple of thoughts, obviously, what you
say. Yeah, this is an important question.
So there's a few different things, Bethany.
First of all, if the things Joe Biden if Joe
Biden is dealing with actual emergencies via
executive order, then you have to do it as
quickly as possible. And so if if we agree,
some of these things have to be changed right
away. And I agree that some of the things
that that that Biden did via executive order
do have to be changed right away. You do the
executive order and then you try to get a
more permanent legislative infrastructure
in the next two years during which Joe Biden
will have the control of the House and Senate.
So that that argument, the idea that you don't
need to do any executive orders because you
have control and you can do it all, that,
that that's not a good argument, number one,
because if you have an actual emergency, you
need to deal with it as quickly as possible.
Number two, not everything can be done with
a simple majority. There are things that that
require 60 votes in the Senate in order to
get done. And so it's not quite so simple.
Now with something like covid relief, I'm
ready for Biden to stop the meetings with
Republicans. It was fine to do the meeting.
It was fine to listen to Republicans who want
600 billion instead of one point nine trillion.
But you can use budget reconciliation to pass
covid relief with a simple majority and it's
time to do it. So I think that any you know,
any time you hear such a general critique,
Bethanie, like Biden doesn't need to do any
executive orders because he has the House
and Senate and can just do everything legislatively.
It's such a general assessment that it almost
certainly it falls short as an analysis. And
that's exactly the case. It's much more complicated
than that.
Gotcha. Yeah, that makes sense, and I had
forgotten that part about, you know, of course,
things sometimes require more than a simple
majority that is absolutely accurate.
And it takes time and it takes time. I mean,
even even without Republican obstruction,
a lot of these things do have to go through
committee. And, you know, I'm not defending
the speed at which the covid stuff is being
done. I would have liked to see Biden do the
meeting with Republicans on January 22nd,
and we could already be moving beyond it.
But I understand why he's giving them a meeting
now. It's just time to act and get it done.
Yep, and I like what you said about, you know,
if it's true that they want to follow up some
of this stuff with legislation that does have
a longer, you know, hold. Yes. That that makes
more sense to and that is what I will come
back with when I hear that talking point.
Yeah. I mean, the critique that in general,
executive orders are a problem because the
next president can just undo it. That's always
been a critique. That's that's not that's
not different than something that could be
said in the past. That doesn't really change
whether for the time being that executive
orders can be done. Joe Biden is right or
wrong to use them.
Gotcha.
Well, thank you. Yeah, that's really all I
mainly just listening, but I did have that
question that's been popping in my head while
I've been watching your show this week.
All right. Thanks, Bethany. Bethany from Oklahoma.
Great to hear from you and hope to hear from
you again.